all right so here's part 2 of how to
find loyal leaders that you can leave
point number nine point number nine
treat everyone fairly but not equally
let me explain to you what I mean by
this I visit so many offices and I see
so many businesses that are ran in a way
and they don't even know it they're
running it in the old Russian regime
that was purely communism and I'll
explain to what I mean by that they
treat everybody equally and fairly there
isn't anybody that's not being treated
better and they're spending more time to
because of performing a different level
if you if you create that kind of an
environment here's what will happen
you'll keep the lower performers with
you but you will not keep and retain and
have royal high high performers in your
organization can you imagine if you're
full Jack's I want you to think about
this I'm Phil Jackson you're Kobe Bryant
or Michael Jordan you're coming to the
team and at any point we can only have
five players on the floor and five
players we have a total of 48 minutes of
play time we're talking about roughly
240 minutes of play time right now I got
12 players typically a great player will
get 35 to 45 40 minutes of play time can
you imagine if I tell all the players at
12 minutes guys listen here's what we're
going to be doing I think we need to be
more he call
we got 12 players here everybody is
gonna get 20 minutes of play time for a
total of 240 minutes everybody is what
do you think Michael Jordan would do he
would leave your team and go to somebody
else and Phil Jackson would never do
that if you didn't perform you didn't
your play time you would bench you and
he may bench you for nine days nine
games 10 games so goes would Pat Riley
and Bill Belichick than the great
coaches because they don't treat
everybody equally they treat people
fairly but they want performers and if
you want to create an environment where
you're higher achievers are loyal to you
you need to understand how what kind of
a regime what kind of a organization
what kind of a culture you are creating
around
more towards communism or you more
towards capitalism degraded by
capitalism and free enterprises and
everybody's the capitalist type and
someone something that capitalist are
natural tendencies is a tendency of a
capitalism our natural tendencies will
tell us what we're really all about we
like recognition we like to do things
individually that we get recognized as
well on top of collectively as well
sports is purely capitalism and so you
got to learn how to treat everybody you
know fairly but not equally point over
ten you cannot challenge everybody the
same way I see so many meaning the way
they challenged this guy is the same
exact way they challenge this gal is the
same exact way they challenged us
everybody's different on the books I'll
actually recommend to you on that is
five love languages I recommend every
CEO business leader Sales Leader anybody
that's doing any vice president
marketing director to read this book
five love languages here's why the book
is about relationship so what doesn't
have to do with sales everything it says
there's five ways people like to have
love shown to them one is words of
affirmation you're so amazing you're so
great towards quality time some of your
leaders want you to put some one-on-one
time into them three years receiving
gifts hey I've got a book for you I've
got a gift for you four is acts of
service and five is physical touch
everybody is different by the way
players and performers don't all come in
the same shape size personality color
everyone's different but what you're
looking for is this you're looking for
fire in the belly you're looking for
heart you're looking for somebody who
wants to get after it has nothing to do
with how many degrees they have how much
education they have what backward it has
nothing to do with that you're looking
for this year if you can find this the
rest should work out for you so five
love languages learn how to not
challenge everybody the same exact way
but when you learn how to challenge them
they'll definitely appreciate that as
well when you learn how to challenge
different people point of our love it
it's on you to protect their egos I hear
a lot of times people say this guy's so
egotistical I like to work with guys
that don't have an ego I'm sorry
anybody who becomes a president they
have an ego you know what they think
they are they think they're a badass no
one becomes a president not thinking
they're a badass they got massive egos
to become a president any Jordan any
kobe any Steve Jobs any high achiever
they got massive egos
the challenge your heaven is not the
fact that they have a big ego your
challenge is you don't know how to
relieve people with big egos and explain
the different kinds of egos the lower
level Eagle to me is someone that comes
to you and they want respect they know
they've done things and you got to give
them respect but they want you to help
them up and they want to learn they're
coachable they're teachable they're
learning they can ask a lot of questions
of why why do we do this why do we do
that they're not blindly gonna do
something you need to explain to them
why but generally if use common sense
you explain it to them they'll take it
from you but they have egos the ones
that you don't need to waste your time
with this dose who come and tell you
about a degree they have and how fancy
of a degree it is and all the
lower-level people I'm above everybody
because they have a degree and you guys
don't then they want to go and start
right here without ever done the
lower-level part what I learn in sales
but I'll doing any of that stuff you
don't need to worry about earning their
loyalty let them go to another company
you keep the people that have an ego
that want to perform but this one I'll
tell you best book I'll recommend on
that is this first rate madness see I
love this book and I'll tell you I love
this book this talks about the madness
of crazy performers such as Kennedy
Lincoln this is by far one of the best
books I've read on how crazy people are
out there you want crazy people with big
egos in your company in your
organization that you want to lead so
the challenge isn't finding ego people
the challenge is you're learning how to
deal with other people's ego and not
getting your own ego offended because
you got to drop your ego if you want to
lead other people with big egos if you
got a big ego and you lead with this you
can have a hard time with this by the
way they also want to make sure that you
have an ego as well but you know how to
set it aside and talk to them and
challenge them and give them suggestions
and requests on things to do point
number 12
ask for their opinions regularly and my
organization when I leave my executive
team or finally the leadership team that
I have I always like to ask what did you
think about that how would you have done
it differently what do you think about
this but I also say I want you know even
I'm asking for your opinion there's an
80% chance we're not gonna implement
what you're suggesting but there's a 20%
chance we will consider and do something
about it and they like the fact that you
being fair and open with them so at the
same time out of the 20% of the ideas
we implement guess where 90% of the
ideas came from it comes from your
leaders it doesn't come from you it
comes from them so you got to constantly
ask for their opinion because believe me
so many times people are like in this in
this mess and they think they know
everything and they are not connected
with the people you're spending too much
time golfing your novel no long talking
to a few leaders what they're doing
there's no hands on another thing
Lincoln talks about in this book is he
talks about go out there and circulate
among your troops find out what they're
doing go find out what they're doing but
the key is this the key is to know that
you constantly ask for their opinions
whatever 13 persuade instead of
manipulate so what does this mean look
you ever heard someone say you know that
guy is too calculated way to calculate
oh my everything is calculated to that
guys well why don't you give me that
calculating guy because I liked leading
calculating people do you know why
because when it's times of crisis and
you're in war and the enemy is shooting
you from every single angle what kind of
a leader do you want you want a naive
leader or you want to calculating leader
you see you give me a calculating leader
that's gonna say hey seven of you guys I
want you to go behind that mountain
right there any of you guys go to that
building hide right there in a sniper go
to the top hey you I want you to go over
there the enemy's attacking us you guys
I want you to stay here and make them
feel like this is where we're gonna
attack them from there needs to be
calculating part I like calculating
leaders I don't mind having calculating
leaders but here's the part that people
have a problem with they want to make
sure you are calculating but this is
what they don't want they don't want
somebody that's manipulating everybody
because the better you get a
communication and get better at
manipulating people you cannot the
tipping point of persuasion is right
here you tip you're manipulating it's
only about of you and defending you you
can't be there you've got to be right
here it's about them you're persuaded
they don't mind you persuading them they
don't mind you being calculated they
have a very big problem when you
manipulate people so how do you do that
how do you get them improving that John
Maxwell wrote a book a few years back
bought this at an airport wrote it and
once read it in one sitting
everyone communicates if you connect
with the most effective people do
difference you've got to learn how to
communicate and connect with you people
this is a great book for point number
fourteen don't take credit for their
ideas my goodness I explained this to
one of my friends today
from Chicago and I said there is nothing
more annoying I used to work with this
person in the past and this first one
would come and sit us down and I would
ask ideas and we would spend one day to
day in whose ideas ideas ideas ideas
ideas and then that would go to the
board and they say this the idea I came
up with and then he would go on stage
and since I came up with this idea I
came out with this ideas all the guys
would come up to me and say wait a
minute she said I came up with that idea
why didn't he and she give me the
recognition I came up with that idea Bob
they lost loyalty and typically you know
who you lose loyalty with your
performers they don't like that if
somebody give you the idea give them
credit for giving the idea now that
makes myself to you there's a lot of
people out there that read this book for
the loss of power I'm interviewing them
next week stay tuned because you'll see
the video with them as well there's a
lot of people that talk about the book
40 laws of power and the challenge with
this book 40 laws of power is to teach
you what manipulators will do to you but
it's not about reading this book to be
this book see I read this book to know
what some people that try to overpower
you by manipulating you with the tools
that this book offers this book was
never written for you to do actually
everything who tells this book to do to
other people book says you know go let
other people do the work you take the
credit I'm sorry if you want to build a
team of one person you go do that if you
want to build a team of loyal people
that want to run with you for the rest
of your life that will run through a
wall for a wall for you you gotta let
them read this so they also know that
other people can do this a lot of people
read this book and they don't want to
share with other people go read this
book and see what happens when other
people try to overpower you in
manipulative ways and eventually when
you lose the naiveness because in a
world of competition if you if you're
not sharp and you're too naive you will
be eaten alive in the world of business
and it happens all the time in the world
of business so if you think it's about
let me take the ideas from other people
and take the credit for it guess what
book you need to read you need to read
barbarians two bureaucrats by Lawrence
Miller I spoke to Lawrence Miller
brilliant man consultant and he wrote
this book in the book he talks about
different phases that every society
organization
it goes through there's always an
original profit as the founder right
after the profit is a barbarian people
that are wanted to go run through the
wall and you know take over territories
and sometimes the profit is the
Barbarian and then you have the builders
then you have the explorers then you
have the administrators then you have
the bureaucrats then you have the
aristocrats and then you have the sinner
just that brings the whole thing
together
see sometimes if you're going out there
and you're losing things with your guys
because you're not giving them the
credit you're taking all the credit and
you're so far at the top and you're no
longer connected you don't even talk to
your people they got to go through 50
different people to fund it before they
get a hold of you maybe you're becoming
a bureaucrat and an aristocrat if your
handicap is par you'll probably be first
because you played too much time
spending too much time golfing and
you're not in the trenches with them you
go out there you want to find out if
someone is in the trenches with them see
how bad their golf game is you'll
generally be able to tell if someone's
still in the game how bad their golf
game is I could care less about my game
impressing you I want to care about you
seeing me grow in the organization of
leading the troops that's what I care
about that's what my that's what a CEO
that's what a leader that's what a sales
organizational leader needs to care
about the most now next one I'm a big
fan of giving equity give people to earn
the opportunity to own a piece of the
company for many years companies have
taken the philosophy of you know I'll
give up a pension plan you you get
pension and they give you 30 years do
you really get the best out of them or
do you get the mediocre part of them for
30 years see I want you I want the best
of you and we're all pretty good
babysitters at some point everybody has
babysat somebody but you know who we
take care of the most our own baby do
you know what happens when your leaders
have a shot at owning a piece of the
company it's their baby now it's not
just about you so imagine if a pool of
people owned a company together on a
business together that is powerful when
people are going out there and building
a company like that next point have
examples of successful leaders that you
personally have developed yes John
Wooden John for how long did you
struggle coaching your freshman's that
came out of high school and these kids
that came out of high school everybody
was all
hurricane in their high school they were
the best ones so they would go from
being the guy that everybody in high
school stalks that you got 12 of them
that have all the same mindset how did
you get that guy that come and play for
you for him to be coachable to you did
it happen where eventually I won one
championship and they started listening
she said no it wasn't one championship
because anybody can get lucky and win
one but the moment I want to people
started buying into my philosophy that's
what happened in business you got to
have proof of developing leaders to earn
long-term loyalty of people not once but
it's got to be two or more times of you
having success developing leaders to
earn their respect and the last point
I'll tell you is this don't act perfect
know your flaws I want to know your
issues in the last book because of
that's hypomanic edge you know what
hypomanic edge talks about it talks
about how many people are the link
between craziness and success in America
that is what this book says hypomanic
edge talks about how crazy people are
and it talks about how different people
are and I like knowing that I like
knowing that people are not normal
people have flaws anybody who is too
perfect no one wants to work with a
perfect person because you constantly
remind them of their imperfections and
so those are the 17 points on how to
create a loyalty which organization if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
subscribe to on the bottom as well and a
couple things I will tell you I suggest
you watch this video with your sales
organization and your leadership team
and sharing this video with them and let
them learn it as well don't be somebody
that is too late and you lose somebody
start creating the environment of these
17 points to create loyalty if you got
some questions on the bottom post the
questions I'll ask it if you want
Twitter follow me and Patrick David I
also answer the questions on Twitter as
well and then if you have any questions
I'll responded on both of them and stay
tuned for the rest of will have thanks
for watching the body